if you open any history textbook in this
country you'll learn that the crowning
achievement of the Civil Rights Movement
was supposedly the Civil Rights Act of
1964 and for the first time in American
history the law banned discrimination
based on race particularly in the
context of employment and from that
point forward we were told businesses
would not be allowed to hire or fire
people because they were black or white
or Asian or whatever it was supposedly
the dawn of a new era Lyndon Johnson
might have escalated our role in Vietnam
but at least he finished what JFK
started and signed the Civil Rights Act
and and we should all be thankful for
that that is the comic book version of
civil rights law anyway which also
happens to be what pretty much everybody
believes to this day
the truth is different though the truth
is that in 2023 the Civil Rights Act is
not simply a dead letter it is a
document so defunct so pointless so
irrelevant that it stopped prohibiting
racist employment discrimination several
years ago and and no one even noticed
when it happened
at least since 2020 and probably much
earlier the largest corporations in this
country have openly discriminated
against white people solely on the basis
of skin color and to be clear we're not
talking about uh quote-unquote holistic
discrimination or discrimination at the
margins here we're talking about a de
facto near total ban on hiring white
people so here are the numbers and
there's no need to
you know hype this up or use hyperbole
because the numbers by themselves are
are shocking like hard to believe
in 2021 the largest public companies in
the United States meaning the companies
in the s p 100.
they hired uh collectively 300 000
people in that year
now of those 300 000 people
only six percent of them were white
so a total of 94 of them were so-called
people of color meaning blacks Hispanics
and so on
now this is data so extreme that it
doesn't even seem to be real even if you
know that anti-white discrimination is a
real problem and it's happening in this
country and it's uh you know mainstream
even if you knew that when you hear
these numbers it's again hard to believe
these are the kinds of numbers that
appear at first glance to be impossible
but they're not impossible the biggest
corporations in the United States with
the best funded legal departments in the
entire world implemented this virtually
absolute ban on hiring whites without
any any regard to the hallowed Civil
Rights Act
and there was not a single news story
about it there was not a single member
of Congress of either party who paid any
attention to the fact that 94 of new
hires among the biggest corporations in
the United States were non-white
now to be fair as this was happening
companies in the s p 100 insisted that
they weren't targeting whites in
particular for example here's one apple
executive telling the Washington Post
that their main goal in the era of
George Floyd is not to punish anyone
instead Apple said they just want to
honor the victims of supposed racial
Injustice and create a more Equitable
playing field watch
so Apple has taken a an holistic
approach a sort of approach to to
criminal justice education small
business or economic uh empowerment why
this approach as opposed to say a more
concentrated approach that focuses on
one of those issues
great question I think we wanted to try
to touch the places where we thought we
could have impact and in honor of how
this all got started you know our racial
equity and Justice initiative is three
years old it started in the wake of the
George Floyd the Brianna Taylor
um death and
we wanted to honor their their
encounters with the criminal justice
system which was so deeply unfair to say
that those murders as they happen should
also there should be work done in that
area as well
yes we have to honor that we have to
honor these uh these scumbags we have to
honor these criminals drug addicts and
drug dealers we have to honor them we
have to honor them by making sure that
only six percent of our jobs go to white
people by the way white people still
account for I think like 70 percent
of the U.S population in total so that's
six percent of the jobs going to 70
percent of the population
now you on the other end uh Black
Americans account for about 13 of the
population
and if you see a disparity where only
six percent of a certain kind of job are
going to 13 of the population we're told
this is a massive massive problem
and this is systemic racism
so six percent to 13 would be systemic
racism terrible awful it's slavery it's
Jim Crow but six percent jobs going to
seventy percent now uh well well that's
that's there's nothing nothing to see
here
the executive at Apple goes on and on
with a bunch of uh uh platitudes and she
never mentions that the s p 100 is going
to unperson hundreds of millions of
white people effectively
she never says that apple is going to
start running ads with a diverse array
of overweight Multicultural actors
having a little sit down with an obese
rendition of Mother Earth
Apple like so many other companies in
the s p 100 tried to keep its hatred of
white people under wraps and for the
most part they succeeded
we only know about what's happened here
because of an article in the left-wing
Bloomberg News of all places and
Incredibly enough
this was not an article condemning the
over racist discrimination of the s p
100 not at all this was not a
breathtaking piece of investigative
journalism that demanded answers as to
why the most powerful corporations were
not hiring whites because they're whites
instead the article from Bloomberg made
this racial discrimination sound like a
great thing Bloomberg endorsed endorsed
it more or less here's the headline from
Bloomberg News
and again this is the only reason we
even know about this
the only only Outlet reporting on the
fact that's only six percent of the jobs
went to white people is Bloomberg but
here's how they framed it Corporate
America promised to hire a lot more
people of color it actually did
the relief from Bloomberg was palpable
thank God that thousands of white people
didn't get hired in 2021 Bloomberg was
saying in fact Bloomberg went a step
further than that Bloomberg also
published the story under a banner
reading equality
so they acted like it's a win for
equality to reject the vast majority of
white applicants that's equality
because nothing screams equality like
preventing white people from getting
jobs that's equality
what Bloomberg did is collect data from
the U.S equal employment opportunity
commission which by law requires that
large companies report their
demographics to the government and in
the in the in the interest of full
disclosure we have to note that we
haven't seen all this data because
Bloomberg hasn't published all of it and
a lot of this is not posted by the
government online either but from what
Bloomberg has disclosed and from
publicly available records we can make a
few determinations and for one thing and
this is a minor point but it's important
to make it anyway
from what we can tell the data appears
to be counting Hispanics as people of
color so you'll notice that when
Hispanics commit violent crimes like
running over retired ex-police Chiefs
with stolen cars for example they're
listed as white unofficial records but
in this case they're considered people
of color
make of that what you will so if they
get a job as a person of color if they
commit a crime they're white
the other point uh more important though
is that Bloomberg's data only captures
hiring by companies in the s p 100 and
that includes some of the most
recognizable and biggest companies of
course in the world like apple Amazon a
t Exxon Mobil Citigroup CVS Boeing and
so on but it doesn't include the vast
majority of companies in this country
including small businesses
in all Bloomberg reports the
corporations the s p 100 hired around
320 000 people in 2021 for comparison
that year the U.S economy added around 6
million jobs overall so what are all the
other businesses in this country doing
are they also rejecting white people
because they don't have enough melanin
in their skin
that's a very good question it's one
that Bloomberg doesn't answer from what
we can tell looking at data from the
Bureau of Labor physics thankfully the
answer right now is no so this trend
seems to be limited to the largest
companies in the s p 100 overall there
has not been as much of a trend among
most small businesses and mid-sized
businesses in this country to stop
hiring white people that's a good thing
instead we're dealing with a top-down
artificial system of anti-white
discrimination that only the very
biggest companies uh are engaging in of
course it's also true that
you know most companies could not
possibly afford to ban the hiring of
white people that would leave them with
a pool of qualified applicants so small
that they would go under within a week
they just they couldn't do it so if
you're looking for the kind of glass
half empty interpretation on all this
data you might say that the companies
that could afford to stop hiring white
people did
and the ones that couldn't afford it
didn't
either way there's no way to minimize
what's happening think about all the
qualified white people who were passed
over for jobs think about how many
careers were completely derailed
in many cases before they even started
because of this
think about the cultural consequences of
having flooded the market with Legions
of under-qualified workers at companies
that that I mean these aren't just any
companies these are companies that make
our Jets and fly our planes and design
our Electronics
this is a massive and unprecedented
catastrophe nothing like this has
happened in modern history
at the same time we do need to recognize
that this discrimination is artificial
there is no consensus in this country
that white people aren't worth hiring
most businesses seem to understand that
discrimination against white people is
immoral not to mention bad for business
or both
whatever the case they're not doing it
it's the corporations at the very top of
the Heap the ones with the most power
and the lobbyists who can control public
policy they're the ones who are pushing
this
they're the ones driving the overt
anti-white racism that we now see every
day
and everywhere in society
you know yesterday we talked about um
this anti-white bias in the courts but
really it's all over the place it's the
reason why people can't get jobs in many
cases the reason why many white people
are unable to provide for their families
they fall into Despair and die of
suicide and Drug overdoses at a rate
that would have been unfathomable just a
few years ago
Bloomberg didn't make any of that clear
but that's exactly what is happening
now why is it happening
I mean why are these corporations
pursuing this anti-white anti-capitalist
flagrantly immoral agenda of mass racial
discrimination
what possible explanation can can there
be for this
well if you look at Bloomberg's website
there's some suggestion of an
explanation you know we all have a lot
on our schedules with how much we have
to do every day soccer practice science
fairs prepping for the holidays Etc the
good news is you can take one big thing
off your plate by putting great meat on
your plate with good ranchers you care
about what your family eats and so does
good ranchers that's why they've spent
years building relationships with local
farms to Source the best 100 American
beef chicken pork and now wild caught
Seafood too the best of the land and the
Sea can now be conveniently delivered to
your door right now they're offering two
years of free ground beef to anyone who
subscribes that's a 480 value two years
of free high quality ground beef and a
locked in price no other Meat Company
guarantees you 100 American Meat and
locked in prices that's because no one
else is good ranchers you can save on
your beef chicken and pork by locking in
your price today every single Steakhouse
quality cut is individually wrapped and
flash frozen to make Meal Time easy Act
Fast since this deal won't last forever
go to goodranchors.com today use my code
Walsh for 25 off and free ground beef
for two years remember subscribe to any
box to lock in your price on America's
best meet for two whole years as well
that's goodrancers.com today and use my
code Walsh for over 500 in savings
subscribe to good ranchers American Meat
delivered Bloomberg boasts that in 2020
as people were dying and police stations
were being torched to honor the legacy
of uh blessed Saint George Floyd
Bloomberg reached out to the
corporations in the s p 100 quote that
summer Bloomberg news reporters and
editors started a project to hold
companies accountable to these pledges
by trying to collect data on Workforce
diversity that's usually kept private we
asked the entire s p 100 to share
information on their worker demographics
we targeted those companies because they
employed millions of people in the U.S
and they're influential lucrative and
sit across a broad swath of Industries
in other words as BLM Riders lit major
cities in this country on fire Bloomberg
reached out to companies like apple and
Amazon told them that they'd better stop
hiring white people told them that we're
going to be watching you better not be
hiring any white people that was the
import of what they were saying and now
three years later Bloomberg is gloating
that these companies did in fact stop
hiring white people
but they're not mentioning that they
pressure these companies to do that
so this is activism journalism at its
finest it's a it's a case study in it
now this is not to blame Bloomberg for
what's happening of course Bloomberg was
merely taking advantage of a
vulnerability that already existed
they were one one of many major media
Outlets that saw that major corporations
feared one thing above all else which is
that there would be an article written
accusing them of being racist
the biggest corporations in the United
States were more worried about being
called bigots than they were about
hiring competent employees
Bloomberg saw a market opportunity and
they took it and that's why they're
celebrating right now
now for the rest of us for people who
care about the future of this country
this isn't just a wake-up call
it's a reason to ask every company in
the s p 100 where they stand on the
information that Bloomberg is currently
reporting do they also hate hundreds of
millions of American citizens solely on
the basis of how they look
or do they recognize that What's
Happening Here is a grave Injustice one
that is endangering everyone in the
country and ruining millions of lives
corporations need to start answering
those questions
and if they can it's time to treat them
the same way Joe Biden's doj treats
quote unquote White supremacists
we need to stop buying their products
you just stop putting up with their
holistic approaches to anti-white racial
discrimination
it's time instead to destroy them
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
Walsh show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts